SPEAKER: Looking for ways
to easily and securely share
data and insights across
organizational boundaries?
Give me one minute
and I'll show you
how with Google
Cloud Analytics Hub.
Analytics Hub is an
exchange platform
that reduces friction for
publishers and subscribers
for sharing data,
machine learning models,
and other analytics assets
within a strong security,
governance, and
privacy framework.
For example, you can augment
your analytics and ML
initiatives with third
party and Google Data sets.
You can share assets
with your partner network
or within your own organization,
and if you're a data provider,
you can build out a
monetization program.
Because it's built on BigQuery,
Google's petabyte-scale cloud
data warehouse, there are no
servers to deploy or manage
so administration is a breeze.
As a data publisher,
you can share data
with as many subscribers
as you want in real time
without having to
replicate your data.
You can quickly build a catalog
of analytics-ready data sources
with granular permissions
that allow you to deliver data
to exactly the right audiences.
Then, you can track
and manage subscribers
and see usage metrics.
As a subscriber,
you can easily find
the data you're looking
for, combine shared data
with your own, and leverage
the built-in ML, geospatial,
and natural language
capabilities of BigQuery.
You can take advantage
of the native BI support
with Looker, Google
Sheets, and Data Studio,
or connect to any of
BigQuery's technology partners.
Analytics Hub is accessible
directly within BigQuery,
making it easy to
publish, curate, discover,
and subscribe to the assets
that deliver immediate business
value.
So next time you're looking
to use shared data to drive
innovation to new
heights, take a minute
to look at Analytics Hub.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/analytics-hub.
[MUSIC PLAYING]